[Music]
on this september 11th 20 years since
the 9 11 terror attacks
remembering the day the world changed
and set off the war on terror paying it
forward they opened their hearts we fell
in love with them one american finds a
way to keep the bond strong with the
people of gander jody wilson raibl's
tell-all the accusations against her
former boss
[Music]
and win or lose the world is watching
leila fernandez
global national with robin gill
michael george ochinski
garnet ace bailey
david michael barkley
kenneth william besnicki
24 canadian names were among the nearly
3 000 read out in new york today a
tribute to the men women and children
who died 20 years ago in the 9 11 terror
attacks
good evening and thank you for joining
us memorials were held across the united
states and around the world today
marking a tragedy that would change the
course of history on september 11 2001
terrorists hijacked commercial planes
and launched an attack on the united
states that shook our security as
jennifer johnson reports two decades
later the memories are just as painful
christie a
adamo the names of the lost were
remembered at the ground zero memorial
every one of the more than 2700 people
killed in new york on the morning of
september 11 2001.
two moments of silence were held to
commemorate when each plane hit the
towers u.s president joe biden attended
the somber ceremony along with former
presidents barack obama and bill clinton
two decades have passed but for those
who lost loved ones it seems like
yesterday in the last 20 years my family
and i have at times known unbearable
sorrow and disbelief about the lives
that would never be
firefighters remembered the men and
women who died trying to save the lives
of others a city still healing 20 years
after the worst terrorist attack on u.s
soil
in shanksville pennsylvania bells were
rung in remembrance by the two emergency
responders first on the scene after
united airlines flight 93 went down as
passengers tried to stop the terrorists
there's one thing to say i know i should
step up
another thing to do it i'm excited
that's genuine
president biden chose not to give a
nationwide address on this day but
americans did hear from former president
george w bush the nation's leader on 9
11.
the world was loud with carnage
and sirens
and then quiet with missing voices
that would never be heard again
a ceremony was held at the pentagon 2
where terrorists crashed american
airlines flight 77 into the building
that houses the country's top military
leaders never forget those who were
murdered by terrorists
never forget those who rushed to save
their lives and gave theirs in exchange
this anniversary comes less than two
weeks after america's chaotic end of the
war in afghanistan that began after 9
11. a war that killed mastermind osama
bin laden but left behind other
extremists america's defense secretary
who fought in afghanistan promised the
job is not over
it will always be our duty to fulfill
their missions
and to live up to their goodness
twenty years later americans are
concerned that al qaeda the terror
network behind the 9 11 attacks will
regroup in afghanistan the pain of this
day remains fresh in millions of mines
with renewed fears something like this
could happen again
jennifer johnson global news washington
it was a day of remembrance in several
canadian communities
[Music]
the town of gander newfoundland marked
the day with live performances and a
dedication of a piece of steel from the
world trade center the town took in
nearly 7 000 passengers whose flights
were diverted
turning now to the election campaign
liberal leader justin trudeau had
conservatives and the black quebecois in
his sights today with stops in the
greater toronto area and quebec but he
couldn't shake an opponent from an
earlier time his former justice minister
jody wilson-raybald an excerpt from her
new book accuses him of wanting her to
lie abigail beeman joins us with more on
the allegations abigail
robin jodie wilson-raybould's book is
called indian in the cabinet speaking
truth to power in an excerpt published
in the globe and mail she details two
conversations she had with justin
trudeau just days before she resigned
from cabinet in 2019.
wilson raybald writes he used the line
that would later become public that i
had experienced things differently i
knew what he was really asking what he
was saying in that moment i knew he
wanted me to lie to attest that what had
occurred had not occurred i did not want
her to lie
i would never do that i would never ask
her that
that
is simply not true saturday trudeau kept
repeating the issue was picked apart
before the last election and it was in
the house in the media in committee i
experienced a consistent and sustained
effort by many people within the
government to seek to politically
interfere in august 2019 the federal
ethics commissioner found trudeau had
violated conflict of interest rules on
the question of whether then justice
minister and attorney general wilson
raybald faced pressure to interfere in
the corruption case against snc leveling
that fall wilson raibled ran and won as
an independent she's not running again
now through it all trudeau's defense has
remained the same i'm not going to
apologize for standing up for canadians
jobs this case it was making sure that
we were standing up for thousands of
jobs he evaded questions about the
timing of the book release and whether
it will affect his campaign and it's
unfortunate to see how things
went from there
and i
carry
the responsibility for
much of it
but
i can't
let that
slow me down his campaign certainly
didn't slow saturday hopping from
battlegrounds in ontario to quebec but
the release took up oxygen in a tight
race shocking not surprising because
this is what
ms
jody wilson-rabel had been saying for a
long time miss wilson raybould felt
pressured to lie from the prime minister
that is completely unacceptable wilson
rabel declined an interview her book
comes out next week which means you'll
likely hear about it again along the
campaign trail which can't help the
liberals robin
abigail beeman reporting tonight police
in london ontario have now laid charges
after gravel was thrown at trudeau
earlier this week he was boarding his
bus during a campaign stop when the
stones were thrown twenty-five-year-old
shane marshall has been charged with one
count of assault with a weapon he was a
riding president for the people's party
of canada before being removed in
response to the allegations
conservative leader erin otul finished
up two days of campaigning in the
greater toronto area today the liberals
hold the majority of seats in the region
and as our chief political correspondent
david aigan explains o'toole's pitch to
voters there is all about putting
someone from the gta in the prime
minister's office for the first time
now is the time for a prime minister
from the
gta in all its history canada has never
had a pm from a greater toronto area
riding but aaron o'toole from the riding
of durham on the eastern fringe of a
region best known by its area code the
905 is bucking to be the first it's time
canada had a prime minister from the 905
from the gta
it's time we had a prime minister who
personally knows and understands the
challenges facing our communities
because i grew up here raised a family
here o'toole who was once a go train
commuter himself is pitching support for
big public transit projects like new
subway lines and new regional rail
projects his ottawa knows best approach
to housing transit inflation crime and
health care
is simply not working for gta workers or
their families for more than a decade
perhaps even longer reducing commute
times has been a top topic for all
campaigning politicians but o'toole has
not provided funding in the platform for
the billions these projects would cost
and of course their completion would
depend heavily on a provincial
government and local governments robin
david aiken in whitby ontario for more
on the conservative campaign and the
party's change in tactics let's go to
mercedes stephenson in ottawa hi
mercedes
hi robin so you know the conservatives
really looking at this campaign for
where they can find swing voters and
that has largely been a move towards the
center some have criticized that saying
there's policy flip-flops or if you
don't like what aaron o'toole has to say
just wait five minutes and he'll change
his position but other conservatives say
look this is a pragmatic move to try to
get people who are not hardcore liberal
voters to vote with the party mr o'toole
has been saying the party has changed
and that people can trust it i sat down
with him and asked him what he meant by
that here's what he had to say
what does it mean when you say the
conservative party has changed and you
could trust us were you untrustworthy
before did you feel this didn't appeal
to canadians take us through that
message we did need to re-establish
trust obviously we lost the last two
elections
and in some areas particularly for folks
here in in the gta they didn't see us
putting up policy that met their
expectations say on the environment
climate change for example
so that's mr o'toole he'll be on the
show tomorrow the second in our series
of leaders interviews robin mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thanks mercedes ndp
leader jagmeet singh is laying out the
cost of his campaign promises he's the
last of the three major party leaders to
put a price tag on his platform global's
richard zissman is here to break it down
for us richard
robin nine days until election day and
finally the ndp releasing that costed
platform and the promise from ndp leader
jug meat singh
is that taxes will not go up for the
middle class
it is the backbone of the ndp's fiscal
plan tax the rich i'm proud to say that
we are the only party that has a plan
that will
ensure that we are not going to put any
extra burden on working class people on
the middle class the ndp the last of the
big three parties to release a costed
platform from the parliamentary budget
officer more than 40 billion dollars in
new spending and investments next year
alone a big part of paying for it a
wealth tax
one percent tax on every penny over 10
million dollars in individual canadian
earns forecast to bring in 10.9 billion
dollars next year there is 14.6 billion
dollars in an excess profit tax coming
in for companies who made more during
the pandemic than before it and billions
more in capital gains in corporate tax
changes
it is a real path forward that's going
to start asking those at the very very
very top to start paying their fair
share and this is where the money will
go billions more for child care the
canada recovery benefit employment
insurance and to compensate families for
indigenous children who were taken away
from them after two thousand six their
sixty eight billion dollars over five
years for new health care spending
including billions for dental coverage a
pharmacare plan starting in 2022-23
and a critical health workers fund i am
proud to say we are the party that is
offering the highest amount of transfers
for health care we should not be a
surprise as for balanced budgets even 10
years down the road they're nowhere to
be seen in the plan there's a path and
our path is that that path to get to
that point should be about increasing
revenue making sure that the ultra
wealthy are paying more of their fair
share like they used to and we're the
only ones laying out a credible path to
getting to a position where we're in
balance that doesn't actually cut help
to people or put burden back on the same
people that have struggled now it's
about selling the costed platform
singing the ndp will head through
ontario to hit a number of swing ridings
starting on sunday robin richard sisman
in vancouver
in newfoundland and labrador they're
cleaning up from hurricane larry
larry was a category 1 storm when it
came ashore with 120 kilometer an hour
winds heavy rain and a high storm surge
along the coast it knocked out power to
about 60 000 customers at one point but
larry didn't linger long the fast-moving
storm is now post-tropical and well out
to sea headed toward greenland where
it's expected to bring significant
snowfall
coming up the battle of the teens at the
u.s open
it was an exciting day on the tennis
court at the u.s open nineteen-year-old
leila fernandez made it all the way to
the final match after becoming one of
the tournament's breakout stars she may
have lost her match against another teen
sensation but as mike julie explains
fernandez's future is bright
teenagers slugging it out in the u.s
open final has gen zed arrived or what
on one side of the net montreal born
leila fernandez and on the other the
uk's emma radekanu who was born in
toronto for two weeks they've captivated
new york's fickle tennis fans sadly the
magic had to end for one and while
fernandez fell short in the final she's
still only 19 years old i hope to be
back here in the finals and this time
with a trophy
the right one with the right trophy
come on come on come on come on
fernandez was a long shot to get here
but nobody can say she didn't earn it
her family made sacrifices with finances
tight her mother moved to california to
work for three years
which allowed her dad to coach her and
she stayed focused even as the naysayers
tried to convince her to quit they kept
saying no that i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna be a professional tennis player
that i should stop and just pursue going
to school she came up to me and she was
really hurt about it you know she was
really you know
it really i noticed that it really
touched her really deeply well now she
can smile not that she hasn't been all
along and begin reaping the rewards
provided she proves she has staying
power you can buy on hype and then you
lose on results later on so
uh if you know
the endorsements can be performance
related i mean you basically had two
people in the final at the us open that
both came out of nowhere but will they
continue to to be at that top level
we've seen it before eugenie bouchard
looked like the next big thing until she
wasn't and lost big deals with coke and
nike it's now leyla fernandez's turn to
play with fame
let's hope she serves up an ace
microlight global news toronto
still ahead veterans and their families
grapple with the legacy of 9 11.
[Music]
this is the first anniversary of 9 11
without u.s troops in afghanistan it's
only been a few weeks since the american
withdrawal and for those who served
today is especially painful as jackson
proskow reports they're struggling to
come to terms with a 20-year war effort
that was erased in a matter of days
from the ashes of the world trade center
and the pentagon rose america's longest
war
a grieving nation sought to find those
responsible and stop another attack
911 is always hard for me tom amenta
served two tours in afghanistan in 2002
and 2004 he risked his life with pride
and purpose
we had a high value target list of
people that were directly responsible
for 911 and we were going to find them
and we were going to either capture or
kill death that was it
two decades later the end of the u.s
mission carries far less clarity
afghanistan is back under taliban
control there's not a single u.s troop
on the ground the truth is i can't get
around the fact that i absolutely
believe that something bad is going to
come back out of that country in the
next seven to ten years for many
veterans and their families this
september 11th feels more painful
grief mixed with anger and one lingering
question
was the war worth it i do not feel that
my son died in vain
i think it's important for me to make
that clear jill stevenson's son ben was
just 13 when he watched the twin towers
fall
from that point on he vowed to serve his
country becoming an army ranger he was
killed in a fire fight with the taliban
in 2009 at age 21.
it's very sad
and maddening to watch
20 years
of blood sweat and tears of our military
just get
wiped off you know wiped away um in the
blink of an eye making it worse rubbing
salt into that that wound
for me is that it comes on the heels of
the 20th anniversary of 9 11. dr shelley
amen served in the u.s army before
becoming a psychiatrist who works with
veterans people are feeling it acutely
right now on this september 11th she
encourages veterans and their families
to find support and know that healing is
possible you know they're really feeling
like their
their post-traumatic stress disorder
symptoms are flared up they're feeling a
deep sense of betrayal in a lot of ways
nearly two decades after he left
afghanistan that's what motivates tom
amenta he has worked to document the
stories of those who served hoping to
use this grim anniversary to remember
what was gained not lost in america's
longest war we kept the world safe
around the world not just americans but
canadians you know the aussies everyone
in nato everybody who stepped into that
country and said 911 will not happen
again jackson proskow global news
washington
up next giving back to gander
[Music]
twenty years ago less than ten thousand
people were living in the town of gander
on september 11th that population grew
by nearly seven thousand dubbed
plain people travelers suddenly found
themselves grounded in this small
canadian town but they were made to feel
more than welcome one american woman
keeps returning to repay their kindness
here's ross lord
it takes a special energy to travel more
than 24 hours from ohio to newfoundland
and labrador at age 85. but shirley
brooks jones is determined to keep
saying thank you to the people of gander
and surrounding communities i mean they
didn't have to do what they did for us
they could have just looked the other
way they could have said oh well
somebody else can take care of them you
know but they didn't
shirley and almost 7 000 other
passengers were stranded in the gander
area after the 9 11 terrorist attacks
those newfoundlanders
were absolutely awesome they opened
their hearts their homes their their
churches their service clubs i mean
in a few days
we fell in love with him we we truly did
for 20 years the love affair has
continued
shirley has made dozens of trips back to
gander and lewisport to hand out the
flight 15 scholarship from a fund she
initiated
a smile on her face i wanted all times
into the future
for the people of that area to know
that we would never forget what they had
done for us
live
hundreds of high school students have
qualified for the scholarship including
raylene kirby on her path to becoming a
family doctor i don't know shirley will
ever know
what a role model she's been in my life
as a strong female
leader and
just a beautiful person overall they're
eating the sleeping in the same area
shirley's best friends in lewisport bill
and thelma hooper are excited to see her
again she's just one of our family now
really as a concession to covert 19 this
visit is different i've already told her
that no
we're not allowed not supposed to hog
or even shake hands for surely it's hard
to hold back eventually i'm going to
touch your arm or your face or your or
something else but hugging that's
something you know if you're if things
are good or bad or whatever hugs and not
being able to hug it just about kills
you but even the pandemic doesn't dampen
her enthusiasm for giving back i love
those people i love them even when i die
i'll love them i'll come back i'll come
back and
two decades of kinship and counting ross
lord global news lewisport newfoundland
and labrador
and that is global national for this
saturday night thank you for watching
i'm robin gill we leave you tonight with
today's memorials to the victims of the
9 11 attacks it was a day that will
never be forgotten good night
you